se ha convertido en una escena familiar
cada vez que la lira turca baja los
vehículos griegos y búlgaros se dirigen
a la frontera en edirne en tracia
oriental este mercado es un destino
apreciado por quien los vendedores
llaman con su vecino
esta familia vino de bulgaria
aquí es mucho más barato que en bulgaria
y cuatro veces más baratos compramos
ropa llenamos el depósito y volvemos a
bulgaria
otros en cambio se desplazan durante
horas desde grecia
espectadores los salarios no son muy
altos en grecia entonces aquí para
nosotros es una buena oportunidad de la
estabilidad watch line a la última vez
que viene un euro valía nueve liras hoy
14 así que es mucho mejor para nosotros
ahora con la caída de la libra los
precios suben y el poder adquisitivo
turco se reduce los clientes turcos
especialmente estos dos últimos meses ya
no pueden permitirse comprar todo se ha
vuelto demasiado caro para ellos por
ejemplo con el salario mínimo tres mil
liras apenas podemos comprar lo
suficiente para comer a medida que la
crisis económica se agrava la respuesta
del gobierno a veces resulta
contradictoria por un lado el presidente
dice que es víctima de un complot
internacional contra las finanzas del
país por otro espera convencer a la
opinión pública de que la situación está
bajo control que todo forma parte de un
plan a largo plazo para impulsar la
producción el empleo y el crecer